paraît que tu m'as fait un quiz ouais je
te fais un petit quizz bah c'est pas
pour toi c'est pour les invités mais
j'ai fait un vrai faux surtout à vous
connaissez bien thierry ardisson alors
il ya des choses qui sont vraies
d'autres affirmations qui le sont moins
on va compter les points en régie cet
échappement de rien alors on y va
thierry à du pq noir dans ses toiles est
vrai ou faux vrai
boucher
souffle mon âme
jerry a passé son permis à 60 ans faut
il ne devait pas
aller je tenais bien conquérir
étymologiquement ardisson veut dire
grande gueule
non
non bonsoir je dirais oui juste pour
contredire c'est ton choix qui a raison
en fait c'est sa douce douce en latin
c'est fort et se noue cela bois ça veut
dire la voix forte à grande gueule comme
ça remonte ça remonte à l'antiquité
gréco-romaine
yahvé ouvrir un chêne de kebab rue de
rivoli
oui
et non c'était faux
nick evans ni famille mini hamburgers
rien thierry a été l'amant de soria la
première table du shah d'iran
benoît re
c'était évidemment oui oui qui dit oui
oui c'est thierry c'est déjà faire un
procès pour plagiat
quand il va à un enterrement thierry
s'habillent en blanc
on a tellement dit bartoli oui
thierry porte le même nom que le
camionneur qui a tué coluche
et autant pour moi si tu poses la
question est là aucun intérêt donc oui
bon c'est la wii les mains
hier hip hop le nom d'un serial killer
ouais ouais bah oui c'est pas un serial
killers et nécrophile d'une nuit au 19e
siècle c'est un mec adoré faire l'amour
avec les cadavres qui partait en
vacances à la mer morte
1 soit retiré a rencontré sa fille dans
un club échangiste
il faut non non c'était sa maman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment tu vas ça va très bien j'ai son
cadeau de besson qui s'achève le petit
sachet
ça va ça va très bien qu est-il devient
ça c'est une surprise bravo à la prod
d'un fils jean corti en même temps
c'est plus à lutter annoncé la caméra
explore le temps était la mission alors
je voulais je suis en permission donc je
joue je suis au théâtre et à partir du
13 janvier dans une pièce d'éric
pratique chez nous mais
j'espère bien mais c'est un peu plus
qu'à te voir ben moi aussi vraiment plus
les corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux